welcome to the David Pakman show I am
Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he is away there's a lot happening
in the news that we should just get
right down to it the President of the
United States has demonstrated once
again that he does not have the
temperament to serve in the office
yesterday in an impromptu meeting that
he had in the Rose Garden he
demonstrated the level of belligerence
and incoherence that should concern the
American people he was infuriated by the
fact that Nancy Pelosi had the nerve to
declare that he was involved in a
cover-up well if anyone has been
following alone this far you understand
while that is not an unreasonable
statement from Nancy Pelosi but it was a
statement that clearly triggered the
President of the United States because
this is what he said in the Rose Garden
take a listen in things are going well
and I said let's have the meeting on
infrastructure we'll get that done
easily that's one of the easy ones and
instead of walking in happily into a
meeting I walk in to look at people that
had just said that I was doing a
cover-up I don't do cover-ups you people
know that probably better than anybody I
just wanted to let you know that I
walked into the room and I told Senator
Schumer speaker Pelosi I want to do
infrastructure I want to do it more than
you want to do it I'd be really good at
that that's what I do but you know what
you can't do it under these
circumstances so get these phony
investigations over with
so mr. president mister I don't do
cover-ups he's using a lot of tactics
here that really I mean clearly the
President of the United States is like
clearly he's involved in something
because if the Mullah report exonerated
him to the extent that he declared it
exonerated him he would have released
those documents and completely put it in
to all of this the president was meeting
with congressional leaders in order to
discuss an infrastructure plan and he
was so bothered by what Nancy Pelosi
said that he basically threw the entire
meeting off now I pursed
do not believe that the Democrats should
give this president an inch not a single
inch because we are engaged in one of
the most hyper partisan errors in
American history and by giving the
president an inch giving them an
opportunity to have a win you are
ensuring you're at least aiding and
abetting his reelection and dealing with
the type of president who has no respect
for institutional norms he has zero
respect with respect for the rule of law
he has no respect for checks and
balances if you're not going to impeach
him you sure as hell should not give him
anything to help him get reelected so to
me that part is this entire conversation
about an infrastructure bill is
political malpractice and it's
irresponsible if you believe that the
President of the United States is as
much of a threat as he is but I digress
I came to talk about today the president
losing basically what's left of his
little mind in the Rose Garden because
he could not get away essentially
holding the American people hostage
saying that he will not work on an
infrastructure program if the
investigations continue I'm not a legal
scholar but someone should look and see
if that itself is a form of obstruction
of justice because he's essentially
saying either you end this investigation
or I'm not going to do anything for this
country whatsoever notwithstanding the
fact that Democrats should not give him
an inch on infrastructure but I digress
this is what Hillary night Hillary
Clinton but Nancy Pelosi had to say
about it for some reason maybe it was
lack of confidence on his part that he
really couldn't come match the greatness
of the challenge that we have didn't
wasn't really respectful of the reason
of that Congress and the White House
working together he just took a pass and
it just makes me wonder why why he did
that in any event I pray for the
President of the United States and I
pray for the United States of America
now I'll have a lot to say about Nancy
Pelosi's last sentence that she's going
to pray for the President and for the
United States of America I know she was
trying to convey a sense of somberness
and a sense of seriousness
the situation because the president is
acting in such an erratic fashion that
maybe we do need the intervention of a
divine power but we could also have the
intervention of an impeachment
proceeding but that's not what I'm just
talking about in this segment here's the
problem
Donald Trump does have an issue he seems
to be triggered more by by women than
any anyone else because by far enlarge
everyone is declaring that Donald Trump
is engaged in a cover-up everyone is
speaking to this
oh so many policies even have
Republicans speaking to this because it
is obvious right again I said it before
so many people have said it if he was
exonerated to the level with which he
claims he was exonerated he could end
all of the conversations all the rumors
all of the all of the backroom
questioning that's going on right now he
can enter by releasing the unredacted
Mullah report but he's not going to do
that he's behaving his behavior pattern
suggests that he is seriously trying to
to cover up something or to avoid
getting exposed I want to play a clip
from Chuck Schumer because he unlike
Nessa Pelosi he actually put it into
perfect context with one sentence this
is what he said to watch what happened
in the White House would make your jaw
drop and so that's the problem
that's that's that's the thing that's
happening before our eyes we are
becoming so numb to the fact that we
literally have an unstable manchild in
the White House of whose Perpetual ins
as gotten to the point where he's going
to hold the American people hostage to
preserve himself I do get the notion of
self-preservation but that's why we have
checks and balances the Republican Party
does not have enough to merit Eeyore
backbone to actually stand up to their
dictator in chief but we do have aid an
opposition party that has the capacity
to do so and while they're waiting
around and and perhaps perhaps the
infrastructure offering to Donald Trump
was merely bait a bait and switch but I
don't think so I think the seriousness
with which Nancy Pelosi was speaking
sounds like she was
seriously upset because they couldn't go
forward with an infrastructure building
but regardless we have an opposition
party who is not using the the actual
institutionalize methods at their
disposal to at least bring forth
articles of impeachment and into this
president so he can understand that he
is not above the law right now he's
operating as if he's above the law a few
minutes ago I spoke about the fact that
I believe Donald Trump does have an
issue with how women speak to him
there's a clip from Senator Stabenow
that I want you to hear right now she's
an incredibly smart woman and she's
tough she will work with him but she's
very savvy and I I don't think he does
well with strong smart women so there
you have it you have a petulant manchild
who's holding the United States hostage
and he will not move forward with
improving the United States
infrastructure unless we end the
investigations who was completely
triggered because a woman of power and
influence and intelligence challenges
him that is where we are in 2019 that is
who conservatives elected in 2016 and
that's who we have to do whatever we can
when it comes to 2020 in the election in
2020 one of today's sponsors is impeach
the card slap game you can't slap Donald
Trump in real life but you can slap him
in this really funny and intelligent
two-player card game and you can get it
for 10% off at david pakman.com slash
impeach impeach the card game is perfect
for having friends over hanging out with
family members who have a sense of humor
about trump we've been playing it at my
place I really don't think you'd be able
to find a game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it I think you will too you
can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary in the game we were talking
to the creators of the game and they
said one of the goals was that players
might even learn something new as they
play I think it would make a /
gift for anyone really of any political
orientation because of how clever it is
don't forget Father's Day is coming up
and when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach you'll get 10% off the
game but you can also get 10% off any of
the hilarious clothing and accessories
in the online store including t-shirts
coffee mugs tote bags all featuring
funny original political cartoons about
the president get a super fun and witty
gift for yourself or someone you know
whether it's impeach the card slap game
or any of the other awesome stuff in the
gift shop and get 10% off of all of it
when you go to david pakman.com slash
impeach